good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy what is it oh my
god it's hump day happy wednesday
everyone hope having your hope you're
having a glorious wednesday hey jax how
you doing darn good it's the day
everyone's been waiting for the day on
everybody's lips humpty wednesday
sexy wednesday well it is hump day don't
forget to help someone you love
um of course as every wednesday comes i
will be humping thea
as every day comes you will be humbling
theo but on wednesday it's allowed it's
encouraged yeah let's let's be real with
one another hashtag be real how is three
sand
three sand is doing well um just kind of
ben's in boston for like spritz stuff
for today and yesterday so it's been
mom and sunday and it's been so nice to
be
the apple of theo's eye you know get all
of his attention it's been an absolute
joy mother-son bonding you'd love to see
it
i can't wait for theo's wedding when we
do a mother-son dance and who will theo
be marrying do you think
probably me
so the first dance between bride and
groom is also the mother son
yeah we're killing two birds with one
stone
theo doesn't have a girlfriend
no theo's pretty asexual
it's because he's in love with his
mother
it's because he's in love with himself
actually just like his mother and you
know if you looked like theo you'd be in
love with yourself too guys that's true
no olivia needs to get a female dog that
could be theo's girlfriend just like
bryson knowles i mean get you a love
like bryson knowles you guys well
actually um even though theo i do
believe is asexual if he were to be
sexual i do think he would be more
attracted to male dogs so i would
suggest for better
for the optimum chance of him falling in
love i would suggest olivia get a male
dog okay love that for him
yeah
so that's a little bit about theo
today's wednesday we have an amazing
show we're going to do to your toasters
where we give advice to our listeners
and we try and guide them
through the trials and tribulations of
being alive and there are many so many
they never end
spooky
[Laughter]
how you doing i'm doing good i'm
exhausted i woke up today like with a
thud you know i just am so tired with a
dull headache not bad enough to take a
migraine pill because it's not a
migraine it's just like a
girl slow down headache you know yeah
so i'm just powering through
i'm having like a total opposite i woke
up an hour and a half before my alarm
laid watch tick tocks took my time
getting ready made tick tocks while i
was getting ready listened to shania
twain caught up with taylor strecker on
facetime caught up with brian on
facetime it was really just like a
glorious morning not to be so annoying
childless verse mother yeah i'm so happy
for you
i did start jeanette mccurdy's book two
days ago i forgot to talk about it on
the toast you have a jeanette mccurdy
headline okay i just want to say i'm
like not i haven't made a big dent
in the book i think i'm maybe 20 in and
you guys know i'm such a fast reader i
just i could read a whole book in an
afternoon
but i'm finding this book really
difficult to get through and it's not
because it's bad at all it's actually
really good it's
really heavy
and i don't even think the part that i'm
up to is heavy it's just her like lying
the seeds and really setting the scene
for how her mom was so abusive um and
it's not abuse like you know it's not
painful to read because she's you know
being physically abusive or even really
verbally abusive it's so manipulative
and and like emotional and i know that
jeanette ends up having like a severe
eating disorder and a severe um case of
ocd and you just see like the bricks
being layered and it's like really
actually like heavy
that's really tough is the writing also
pretty dense
no actually like she's in a really good
writer and what i think is really cool
i'm she's only like eight or ten at the
part that i'm at and she's writing like
an eight-year-old but like in a mature
way i can't explain it i think the
writing is actually really good oh okay
great i definitely am going to read it
it's really reminded me of jessica
simpson like we're getting headlines
that are teasing snippets and i'm
feeling convinced but i did want to talk
a little bit about it today and then you
can talk about some of your thoughts
yeah it's like annoying to be reading a
book that's like so in the headlines and
i had gotten an advanced copy of it but
i only got it the day before it came out
so um it's like spoiling like i keep
seeing things on twitter and i just
scroll past it's really annoying yeah
i understand
i want to find some things out on my own
[ __ ]
okay well looking forward to your recap
of that book but i do hope to read it as
well speaking of homework how is your
funny girl assignment going what's the
assignment that you have to go see funny
girl with bean you have to watch the
movie you have to see funny girl with
beanie and then with leah
oh well i forgot i had committed to that
um and i'm obviously behind because
beanie's gone
so
okay
so never mind
you have to watch a movie
i should watch a movie and i did secure
tickets i was not able to get opening
night tickets like in the premium seats
that i wanted so i have the second night
i think it's okay you have tickets
that's great tickets tickets tickets
tickets tickets tickets we got annie so
i'll be on broadway and i'm very excited
like i
actually this morning when i was on tick
tock i fell down like a glee rabbit hole
and it's just it really prepared me to
talk about leah michelle here today got
it and when is opening night
september 6th
september 6th okay cool we'll all be
waiting with baited breath
i'm very excited um so i have something
to look forward to post labor day
because you know the labor day slump is
real summer is officially over
labor day is over long weekend is over
we don't have another one for a while
because like some people don't celebrate
columbus day which i understand but like
why take the day away
um but not for me because after labor
day i got tickets to
celie michelle and funny girl so and
it's also it's fashion week
oh which is huge for me like really
changes my schedule so many events
so many presentations shows luncheons
i forgot about that
oh my god i think for me that's the
hardest part of having like left new
york is missing all the fashion week
fanfare and all the events i was invited
to year after year no and i think that's
like a huge thing that new york is going
to be affected by
you know you leaving means fashion week
is not going to be the same no it's not
it could never be
so that's tough yeah it'll be a
different sort of fashion
yeah totally totally
um
i mean i just i'm so glad you brought
that up because actually something i
wanted to talk about was i'm really
struggling to kind of get my events in
order like post summer i'm just being
invited you know to so many galas and
things like that and it's really really
tough for me to prioritize you know
what's important
what are you invited to maybe we can
help
so obviously the met gala that's in may
and then of course um
fashion week chanel
balenciaga they like please sit for
front row claudia and it's just
you know it's hard because i have to
take care of me
yeah and someone has to take care of
theo
that's why ben is here
uh no do you actually have events or no
oh i mean sometimes you do like i have
shows you're out on the ferry yesterday
giving crunchy ties me
no i have um
funny girl tickets and then a few days
later i have an event
that i actually can't really say it's
not a work thing it's a personal thing i
mean i can't say it but i think in about
a week from now i'll be able to say it
and i think that
that's all i'll say on that okay so i
know what it is
i mean like you don't know what i'm
going to but you know what i'm talking
about okay cool i can't wait to hear
and
that's and then i have shows in
september so i'm going to be in
huntington long island i'm going to be
i think in portland in seattle in
september so tickets available
girlsnojob.com tour great get your
tickets tickets tickets because you
don't want to miss this
i couldn't have said it better myself
um so it's really all the updates for me
yesterday just like worked worked worked
worked a little more same same dress
cleaners and then came home yeah no
yesterday another busy day
just
being a mogul being a mogul and a mother
and it's really hard to do both you guys
you know i think one could say that
every mother is a mogul yeah for sure
for sure like you are the mogul of your
own household um but then i'm also like
working too and it's
for like this billion dollar company
yeah yeah and it just keeps growing and
like there's so much fanfare claudia and
i did the funniest thing last night
we facetimed and claudia realized she
could share her scream can i just say
that feature on the new like ios where
you can screen share or like share music
i was listening to spotify like with
snatcher on facetime it is a premium
premium edition yes so since i don't
have tick tock and claudia was telling
me how like we have all these videos
going viral plus there's two morning
toast fan accounts that clip
moments from our show over the past four
years and some of the funniest moments
and also moments that i just like forgot
about that never thought i never even
thought about at the time and then like
they resurfaced and i'm like damn that's
funny so she was playing them on her
phone on screen share for me and i was
watching them through facetime and it
was a grand all time also because she
can send me sometimes you'll send me a
video and i can enjoy it but
half the fun of tick tock is the
comments
i wanted to know what do you not get
comments on safari no you get like two
that's disgraceful so i wanted to see
all the comments see what people like
are saying about us someone like came
for our gums i guess we have weird
familial gums
i don't know what they're talking about
um
and there's like been so much fanfare on
tick-tock for us like people making
videos like just that they love the
toast talking about like all of our
lingo opening their merch so i wanted
jackie to see the fanfare like our hard
work our you know tick tock videos are
vertical videos like i know you're
seeing the fanfare on reels but it also
exists on tick tock yeah so definitely
that is what is going to get me onto
tick tock like knowing that there's like
fan accounts there's videos of myself
that people are going to make more that
i don't even know exists like aside from
the ones that we make and and i always
want to see the comments on those which
i never get to see but that there's like
other content of me just like living out
there so i am thinking about downloading
tic tac on my ipad
so that like i can dedicate i'd be like
okay now it's time to read the tick tock
comment see what people are saying and
it's not like i'll be scrolling all
night in my bed because i leave my ipad
in my office so it will just be like a
work thing i need to see what the people
are saying about me and my gums
and then i'll move on so that's my plan
i love that plan and i think i should
just like speak directly to the toasters
and be like if you keep making toast
content on tick tock like build it and
she will come so that's the lesson here
yeah and that's really what
what it was i didn't know what it was
going to take for me to get on tick tock
i thought maybe rache parcell i thought
maybe kylie she's doing the most on take
talk but no it was the toasters and
really it's i'm inspired by myself
no that's the thing like if you're not
motivating yourself you're not going to
motivate anyone else who who do you
motivate
exactly yeah
so that was a fun treat
also
yesterday i was on our instagram account
like reading you know people's messages
and comments and literally like i was
cackling
cackling like
i think people are so funny and i think
the toasters are so funny and i just
wanted to say like they don't go
unnoticed those comments like i feel
like people really like work hard on
their comments to be like funny and
clever and they always are and i just
wanted to say it's like one of my
favorite things to do i agree and that's
actually a great segue into my next
point which is that tonight is the
season finale of breaking bread
and breaking bread is a place where all
those comments come to life and we're
able to read and react to them in real
time and like everyone is so funny and
just says the funniest things and i'm
really excited for our final episode
tonight at 5 p.m eastern time on the
spotify live app you can interact with
us we can read your comments on air if
they're particularly funny or you can
just listen on spotify but you just
can't comment and stuff so that'll be
really fun we have to do something
really special for our last show oh we
have to plan something maybe i'll sing a
song yeah but what song
so many options maybe i should do them
all now and then see if people have a
favorite and then i'll do that one
tonight i think people would love i
think everyone who listens to the show
would love that
i think we all are obsessed with
claudia's singing voice
yeah i
i am
um really quickly i just realized that i
am on an antibiotic that i have to take
in the morning and i didn't take it so
can you talk for 30 seconds while i just
run to my purse and and get it sure what
do i want
[Music]
not too much these days but you could
always follow me on instagram at jackie
ashrae premium content some days no
stories on other days but that's just
the kind of gal that i am
also i finally got these swanky podcast
headphones so now i feel so legit
with my sure microphone
and that's what you missed on toast
claudia's back oh and she's drinking her
coffee
she has to prioritize her health
i'm back i talked mad [ __ ] like what did
you say it was crazy i was telling them
like everything oh my god i took my
headphones off i couldn't hear you what
did you say ben you'll have to rewatch
oh i rewatched yesterday's episode i've
been loving you know i'm very anti
watching our own show watching game tape
yeah i'm just honestly like not
comfortable with it
um that's how honestly not like you
no i know because i'm self-obsessed like
the world truly does revolve around me
and i honestly let's be like real with
one another i cannot believe that there
are people out there who don't think
that the world revolves around them like
i know my world revolves around me i
don't think the entire world but like i
do think my world revolves around me and
i just can't believe there aren't people
who like feel that way yeah you know
what that reminds me of randomly just
something that stuck with me when stasi
was on her last season reunion for
vanderpump rules and she was like got
called out for saying that she was like
the beyonce of her friend group and she
was like if you don't think you're the
beyonce of your own life what are you
doing
no totally like
who wants to be michelle yeah no like
who doesn't think that they are the star
of their own life no i'm sure that there
are people who don't think that they're
the star of their own lives but like we
should all be striving towards that
right not making it a negative thing
yeah i agree
um
what was i saying before
you were saying oh that i don't like to
watch our own
show but
in like the last couple of weeks i've
had to watch it just because av girl
gotta know the tech make sure like
things need to be changed lighting
things like that and i've been enjoying
it immensely like yesterday's episode
when it ended i was in
what was your favorite part
oh my god
such a good question there's so many
like
i think the beginning we were just being
particularly like unhinged before we
dove into the story oh yeah people
really liked yesterday's episode i was
reading the comments and um
that's what that's what it was i like
can't think today i'm just gonna give a
psa like my brain is not working
no bueno yeah it's not a good brain day
i need brain camp
okay wait i'm like freaking out because
now i'm thinking maybe i did take my
antibiotic because i woke up so early
and i'm just like really like having a
hard time remembering
is it this is double dose is it the sort
of thing that would be okay if you took
it twice
like yes
i'm just like being dumb you could count
how many are left and how many started
i guess
but that okay whatever i'm not okay
okay maybe we both need brain cancer
that's maybe we should just dive in
maybe we should dive in take the
pressure like stop talking about
ourselves and our [ __ ] up brains talk
about other peoples
hundred perhaps so without further a do
do here are the fastest where are you
bruno loves his auntie
doo doo doo doo
where are you
theo needs a girlfriend
where are you
don't push your heteronormative [ __ ]
on my son
where are you
ceo needs a partner
where are you
don't forget god is a man
where are you
maybe theo should get with god
100
that's really honestly in my opinion the
only suitable eligible bachelor for my
son
our lord and savior
i could just do the rest of the episode
singing do to do the deuce
don't tempt me because honestly don't
tempt me with a good time
that was curing my headache
wow okay how about this does this make
you feel better
theodora
theodora
theodora crunchy angel dora gorgeous
mandora
love of my life dora sweetest puppy dora
crunchy lips dora god's love dora
god's love is so important
god's love dora
did you say fast five did we do the
crunch uh i don't know if we did the
kind no we didn't okay so without
further ado
where is bro
he ran downstairs
[Music]
did it do
where is phil
the only thing wrong with our remote
setup and it's something we're going to
have to work out
is when we sing together we just can't
get like
completely in unison yeah that's why the
dues are so good because we go back and
forth
exactly it's a true duet it's a
duet
okay where was i without further
did it do here are the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
clinique if you have dark spots it can
often feel like a vicious cycle as soon
as one fades another one pops up break
the cycle with the clinique even better
clinical dark spot interrupter this
powerful serum works on melanin rich to
fair skin and it helps visibly correct
dark spots like acne marks while
protecting from future discoloration so
i suffer from uh dark spots as well they
come out really badly when i'm in the
sun so in the summer they're not great
and when i feel like i get them under
control which is super hard they just
come back um and i've been looking for a
really good solution to the dark spots
and clinique is a brand that i trust i
love their foundation by the way um
and the dark spot
corrector is fabulous so 94 of people
have demonstrated an improvement in
radiance and visible skin tone including
acne marks in eight weeks
their damage eraser and their
brightening complex is now more
concentrated with boosted technology to
deliver dramatic brightening results but
it's still gentle enough for all skin
types so in just two and a half hours it
can help it can help quell redness from
irritation that can trigger new visible
spots and worsen existing spots so it's
oil-free non-acne genic it's fast
absorbing and it's dermatologist
approved you can get even better
clinical dark spot correct dark spot
interrupter today which is available at
clinique.com the product for dark spots
is the even better clinical dark spot
interrupter clinique.com also check out
their foundation it is premium as hell
great our first story jeanette mccurdy
reveals what made her forever pissed at
ariana grande
the sam and cat claws are out jeanette
mccurdy says her dislike for ari began
soon after they started filming their
nickelodeon show when she realized the
pop star allegedly got permission to
pursue outside opportunities
so she wrote i booked two features
during icarly that i had to turn down
because the icarly team wouldn't write
me out of episodes to go shoot them
she said that
in her memoir she said producers would
stuff ariana grande's character in a box
so that she could miss filming she
recalls thinking are you kidding me so i
have to turn down movies while ariana's
off whistle toning at the billboard
music awards [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i mean that would piss me off too
yeah she said admitted that once ari was
allowed to ditch filming she snapped
quote i'm pissed about it i'm pissed at
her jealous of her for a few reasons so
now every time she misses work it feels
like a personal attack from that moment
on i didn't like her i couldn't like her
clearly the way that this this is
written is like this was her thinking at
that time
yeah yeah no and i honestly i don't
think that she has hate in her heart for
ariana grande but first of all when
you're a kid like
you're always comparing yourself to
other people like like life should be
fair yeah but you learn as you grow up
life is not fair no but when you when
there's a show called salmon cat and it
is two leads they're two girls they're
the same age like everything they are
the same they're 50 50. like one cannot
have special treatment that is a recipe
for disaster
well i think like what we've learned
about that time at nickelodeon during
the early 2000s or whenever it was like
we've learned a lot about that time
since then and i think one of the things
was that
it was super toxic because there was
special treatment of certain people yeah
who else
um like i think in the victorious cast
there was a lot of that yeah
with victorious
with tori yeah well at least like she's
the headliner not that right anyone
should have special treatment but like
right this is different because it's sam
and cat
yeah and you know it is really
interesting to look at the trajectory of
the careers of ariana grande and
jeanette mccurdy after that show and
that show wasn't on for a super long
time but i also think that i mean i have
to read the book but i just the i
impression that i get is like ariana
came into the industry like with
people you know and like she i feel like
she had
maybe even better people working on her
contracts being like are he's allowed to
pursue other products maybe the initial
contract said she couldn't do other
projects and they went back and like
negotiated her a better deal and like
jeannette didn't have that in place like
who was looking out for jeanette i don't
know
right so the part that i'm up to now in
the book is she is like an agent she's
actually had two agents her first agent
was candace cameron beret's mom was she
a good agent
so she was an agent for her kids candace
cameron and
they said the other her brother you know
she's a famous brother who was on
growing pains okay cool
kirk cameron maybe i didn't i didn't
remember him but so she's tired of
cameron
yes thank you
they she had two kids who were really
big successful child actors so she
started like some sort of agency she was
uh repped by her for a little while and
then moved on to someone else i'm sure
the person she has now in the book is
not her agent for all the other stuff
that she does but her mom was really the
one who forced her into acting who was
making all the calls so if there was
anything like
wrong with sam's setup like it was her
mom's fault yeah but i could see that
having happened
right because her mom is like not a
hundred percent okay like she's erratic
and unreasonable and narcissistic and
like a bull von you know yeah well i
look forward to reading the rest of this
book so i wonder if ari and
sam cat
jeanette have made a repro schmoa since
that time
yeah like where does their relationship
stand now yeah
and the article doesn't say it doesn't
spoil that too no it doesn't spoil that
too um
i mean i can understand like as a kid
hating someone because they get better
treatment um
but as an adult like you realize it's
not their fault i feel like that may be
where she's going with this but she's
just explaining like where her head was
at while filming sam and cat which only
ran for one season
right it wasn't even uber successful you
know what i feel like i mean i have to
read the book and i don't remember and i
didn't look at the ratings at the time
but i feel like it was successful but
like the girls
hated doing it
oh the way that i perceive it just based
on like a feeling so not facts that's my
face is that
is that it was a flop like they both
came from these huge franchises cat from
victorious and sam from icarly and it
just didn't um
take off in the way the others did oh
that's not how i perceive it i feel like
people really liked it but like ari
wanted to do like re tings and and
jeanette like didn't enjoy doing it and
like they didn't want to do it
yeah i don't know maybe they will let us
know
yeah so i really do like i'm super
curious
about like where this story goes i'm
just like having a hard time getting
through it like actually and i don't
really have that problem a lot
interesting okay yeah um i started a
different book last night which i want
to read but then i'll read this
okay i started before we were yours by
lisa wingate it was really popular like
last year the year before um
but now i'm reading it
i don't think it's for you
okay thank you i appreciate it one of
those like i don't know if it was a
reese's book club pick but it's like one
of those
like a novel what are those those are
clothes
um so yes i'll keep you updated on my
reading journey and like anything
interesting i find it find out but the
first really interesting um like name
droppy thing was candace cameron bray
cool keep us posted
and
power through
yes ma'am
next story this is really surprising
news angela yee tweets that the
breakfast club as you know it is
officially over
so that's the whole tweet with two with
that emoji of the heart hands
she tweeted the breakfast club as you
know it is officially over
she remained tight-lipped about the
cryptic announcement but she tweeted god
is good just 15 minutes prior
okay two things one for those who don't
know the breakfast club is like a really
popular radio show um it's kind of like
the toast they go every day and they
just like talk about everything and
they're really funny and people are
obsessed with it and it's been on for a
really long time yeah i think it's also
available as a podcast
you'd love to see anywhere podcasts can
be found
so
that's the first thing the second thing
is that
at first my mind obviously went to oh my
god they're breaking up
but i feel like this is something we
would say like if we got a new studio
you know like
it's never gonna be the same
so i don't know if this is just being
dramatic or actually like teasing
a shift
i feel like it's teasing a shift the
breakfast club as you know it is
officially over i feel like that could
mean a lot of things it can be no more
breakfast club it could mean one of them
is stepping away it could mean they're
getting a force
but it could mean that they're going
officially just to podcast only yeah but
what it does mean is that the breakfast
club as we know it is officially over
which
big if true
that's so crazy i mean it is really
interesting to me how like
i think in terms of shows um when it
comes to pop culture
the breakfast club is like really up
there for like most relevant i think a
lot of people like want to go on it to
promote projects it's really like a big
platform and it's primarily radio which
is just random to me you know yeah i
mean but that's like a lot of things
especially things that start
as big platforms you know yeah well like
howard stern but howard stern is at
least like siriusxm so it feels a little
bit more current like this is a amphum
radio yeah but it's a podcast which
makes it more current and it's as well
as a podcast
yeah i wonder what this means and when
the [ __ ] are we gonna find out i don't
know
but we'll keep you posted yeah of course
charlemagne is on it
what if charlemagne left i think that
would be like really impactful that
would make the breakfast club as you
know it officially over
right
i don't know makes you think but i think
it's like
it's
really a tripod each leg is
i'm staring at my tripod but like it's
that's a really good analogy it's a
tripod yeah each leg is critical
critical so what are we
we are
a bicycle
we are a bicycle and can always get back
on the bike
and you never never forget it's just
like getting back on bicycle and every
time yeah you think you're over the toes
like those girls [ __ ] stuff whatever
and then you're like bored and you come
back see what they're up to what crazy
thing are they saying next thing you're
like
i missed us
okay jackie if we are a bicycle like
we're each a wheel
what's the chain you know the one that
keeps it moving and holds it together
the toasters
no the toasters get to sit on the
bicycle
our blood yeah i would say like our
family is the is the links
yeah yeah yeah
i would say you're the front wheel
uh actually
you know i want to be the front wheel
like that's like if i'm in a dance i
want to be in the middle but
actually i think you
are the front wheel because the front
wheel is the one that turns and like
makes you know
isn't like in charge of the direction
okay
and that's very much like your role on
the show like i just wild out and you
make sure like we actually get through
the show doing all the things we need to
get got it since you say it's the
direction i i agree but i would say like
you're the front wheel cause like you're
the wheel people see first it's like you
know girl with no job like everyone
because i'm bigger because i'm bigger
they see me first because like you're
more known
because you're more known everyone's
like it's girls in a jobs podcast like
you know what i mean
nobody says that by the way like no i
mean you literally like post the clips
to your girl with no job tic tac it's
girl with no jobs podcast yeah like like
i'm the face and you're just like more
private you know and i'm just like that
back wheel that's like anchoring the
thing you know
like i know i know what you're saying
but i think my uh i liked yours too
but both wheels are so important because
i'm very literal it's like in a
technical sense you are the front wheel
yeah yeah yeah
let us know in the comments who's the
front wheel
we'll talk about it on breaking bread
tonight
ooh
chilling anyways so we're a bicycle
they're a tripod i look forward to
hearing what this is and now it's like i
wanted to actually i don't want the
breakfast club to be over but i wanted
to be something otherwise like this was
a waste of of
thinking
um breaking news from the breakfast club
angela yee confirms exit she's launching
her own show
so now they're a bicycle
they're a bicycle so she's leaving
charlemagne and dj envy
she's launching her own show the
breakfast club will continue with the
other two
on 105.1 fm
that's where the oh yeah yeah and
where's her show going to be
she said she's leaving the show after 10
years to launch her own nationally
syndicated daily program for iheartradio
which is the same company that
broadcasts the breakfast club she said
this is really exciting something that
i've been waiting to do for years now
way before the pandemic i have my
podcast lip service and i was thinking i
would be able to get something like a
weekend situation
and then she was approached by i heart
and told that they're gonna give me my
very own show
okay great exciting i'm happy for her
but of course this makes me wonder like
is everything
copacetic with everyone because also
like why couldn't she do her own show
and do the breakfast club charlemagne
does a million other things i think it's
going to be a daily show oh
and by the way at the end of the day
shh like the breakfast club is
charlemagne's show like and it all it
works all together but it's really like
to be honest befo and i'm like familiar
with the
show before
five minutes ago i didn't know that her
name was angela like i like it's
charlemagne everyone knows charlemagne
so she's probably super talented and her
podcast is probably pretty popular which
is like one of the things that like i
heart radio would look at
and be like oh she'd make a good host
for another show and maybe she just
wanted to be her own star which i can
understand you just starve your own life
be the beyonce yeah okay i'm really
happy for her
me too good luck to everyone i think
it'll be good and you know like why
should there be so many good hosts on
one show because there's other shows
with all bad hosts so you need to
sprinkle the good ones that's true so
should we split up
there's too many good hosts on the show
no no no no that's not what i was saying
you guys breaking news the morning toast
as you know it
is officially if we had to do like
separate shows and we were like
competing we would both like doing daily
shows that would be crazy
yeah like mine would probably be better
like av wise but yours would be better
like consistency-wise like you would
actually put up an episode every day
yeah and yours would definitely i feel
like you would skew more towards than
talking about like
you would actually become the show that
i want to see in the world which is like
influencer drama tick-tock drama like
what's going on in the sphere like very
niche celebrity and i feel like i would
just like start talking about the
titanic every day
oh you would literally yours would be
like a grandma show but there's an
audience yeah by the way no i know
but that's why this show is perfect
because you really get it all
speaking of tick tock do we have any
addison race stories no
i can't keep going with her drama
let me tell you
so we spoke a couple weeks ago obviously
her dad was like embroiled in this
majorly tawdry scandal he was like
cheating on his wife whatever addison's
parents
then a couple days ago it was reported
um
that addison unfollowed her mom on
instagram
and somebody posted about it on
instagram like the screenshots from
instagram being like addison unfollowed
cherry and sherry commented
like i'm devastated
thus
confirming now addison rey's dad has
become like a
like a professional troll you have to
see his videos they're blowing up on
tick tock he's acting like a [ __ ]
freak
wanting like offering like to do you
know how jake paul fights people like
he's like i want to fight this person i
want to fight that person making videos
like taunting them he's in having beef
with tana mojo because tana mojo is like
yeah
when that um affair thing happened with
monty uh addison's dad tana mojo was
like yeah we know he's a creep like i
could tell you a million stories he's so
weird then she started posting
screenshots on her instagram of people
who out in la have like had really weird
creepy interactions with addison ray's
dad and she was posting all them and so
monty the dad saw that started like
slut-shaming tana like do we think
tana's body count is over 300 it's like
sir you're 45 years old like leave this
22 year old alone
um he's just losing his [ __ ] mind now
that he doesn't have like a wife to come
home to damn well that's he got what he
wanted
he got what he wanted it's the one you
got
good yeah he got the career he wanted
and it's good because it's the one he
got
okay well thank you for that update and
did you talk about the father son holy
spirit drama
you know i didn't i'm not a hundred
percent um caught up on that i saw she
just released a bathing suit that said
father and son on the bikini triangles
and then holy spirit on her vagine yeah
and people are upset
and to be honest like i hate like when
people get upset like so don't buy the
bathing suit
but like it's
it's like a fence it's just like random
too
it just seems like a hella unnecessary
like and then i have to put my put it in
my shoes like somebody was selling a
bathing suit with like hashem's name on
the vagina like i would be like i would
be upset yeah that is weird
it's it's disrespectful yeah
even if that person was a jew for sure i
agree
she's not a christian
i mean she could be a jew that tick-tock
sound i know you have literally no idea
what i'm talking about and if you don't
watch tick-tock like nobody knows what
i'm saying that tick-tock sound is
heaven on earth
she's not a christian
what's it from
i have no [ __ ] idea okay
okay it doesn't matter she could be a
jew it's so funny okay we need to move
on because new celebrities are jumping
off of yachts in foreman tara
bikini-clad margot robbie leapt into the
ocean during a lavish yacht trip with
her rarely seen husband and her pal rami
malik
have you seen these pics
no but how the [ __ ] do romney malek and
margot robbie know each other obviously
like everyone knows each other i think
from a
movie and i just find it interesting
that they got a lot of film amsterdam
okay i just find it interesting that
they like got along on a personality
level enough to go on vacation together
yeah and is rami still with lucy
i mean i haven't seen anything that they
broke up but they're both extremely
low-key and private so yeah but this
looks like a like something like a
couple's thing couples is she not there
i don't see her and she wasn't she's not
here she's not on the daily
that's no bueno but margot robbie's just
looking sickening like just chilling on
the boat i don't know if she knows that
the cameras are there but like this
looks like an ad campaign
the fact that margot robbie is you know
the most eligible woman in hollywood um
and she shot to fame like so fast
and then she just married like a regular
guy from her hometown i think or at
least from her home country in australia
i just love that about her like do you
know how many like a-list
celebrity
actors would
kill themselves to get a date with
margot robbie and like nobody ever stood
a chance
yeah
i agree but her husband is very nice
looking in these pictures yeah no for
sure but like i'm sure leonardo dicaprio
like wouldn't have you know
try would have tried
when they were on wolf of wall street
yeah who who is she always paired up
with in movies you know how it's like
jennifer lawrence bradley cooper
right
ryan uh wait hold on i mean what has she
been in she was in i tonya she was in
what was her breakout role a wolf of
wall street yeah
um
maybe she doesn't have a guy i don't
think she has like a go-to partner and
what's cool about margot robbie and like
what's so crazy i feel like she hasn't
been famous for that long and she got
famous so fast and she gets the best
roles and that's because she owns like a
really successful production company all
the movies that she's been in in the
last like five years are movies that she
made herself like she's involved in the
script in everything so she's really
actually a mogul
i love that for her i really she's like
reese witherspoon energy like when her
movies are successful it's great for her
acting career it's great for her
production career like it's great for
everyone and i feel like there was
reports a while back that she's the
highest paid actress in hollywood right
now
for sure that tracks
tracks
who was it before jennifer lawrence
google hi it's
because there's always like an actress
of the moment i feel like for like a
year or two it was like lupita nyong'o
or like sam oh number one is sofia
vergara oh this is from well that's on
tv that's true it's sofia vergara and um
judge judy
uh okay so
okay
this includes tv but number 10 viola
davis
number nine elizabeth moss
number eight ellen pompeo
number seven nicole kidman
number six emily blunt
number what tv show wait
what is she on quiet place
okay
it's that people really liked that
i just don't think like it's fair to put
someone on the list for like two movies
you know what i mean and i love emily
blunt like i literally take a bullet for
her number five meryl streep
number four melissa mccarthy
wow number three gal gadot
yes number two angelina jolie
number one was sofia vergara and this
was 20 20.
interesting
yeah
it's just so interesting what makes
people money you know because i think
for a while jennifer aniston was on that
list like for years and years even after
not being on friends and
not
being in movies but it has so much to do
with syndication and brand deals and
things like that and i just find that
interesting like homegirl doesn't even
have to work
yeah
but her syndication makes her like one
of the highest paid actresses like and
she doesn't have to do anything if you
love what you do you'll never work a day
in your life
see
i don't really agree with that because i
love what i do i actually don't think i
could have a better job to be completely
honest like i'm passionate about it i
own my own business i'm good at it i get
to do it with family
um
i like there's nothing about my job that
i do not like
but i still like i roll it's monday you
know
[Laughter]
so i don't believe that statement i do
agree with you
my friend like i get dressed and i'm
like oh my god i'd so much rather be
home yeah
that's human nature ain't it
ain't that the truth
are you ready for our next story someone
else got another job
is it the next story that's brought to
you by bowling branch perhaps yes
yes god bowlin branch uses the best 100
organic cotton threads on earth for
superior softness and a better night's
sleep their sheets aren't just buttery
breathable and impossibly soft to start
but they get softer with every wash
so i have the signature hemp collection
from bowling branch i know jackie has it
olivia had it at her house i just stayed
there for two weeks you have it in your
guest room that i will be staying in
next week we are a bowling branch family
they use the highest quality threads on
earth for a superior softness and a
better night's sleep they're so
luxurious they have been beloved by
three u.s presidents so if it's good
enough for the president and it's good
enough for jackie to be honest she has
extremely high standards when it comes
to these things then it's good enough
for you they're buttery soft to the
touch super breathable great for every
season and they have over 10 000 stellar
reviews get 15 off your first set of
sheets when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com when it comes to
sheets and tings like invest in yourself
sleeping is important how you sleep
really sets you up for how your week is
going to go so we trust swollen branch
and you should too bowling branches
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch dot com promo code
toast for that 15 off and it's a good
chunk so use the code toast great thanks
so much our next story welcome kim
kardashian got another job she has
brought her signature all neutral style
to beats by dre
kim kardashian announced her beats x kim
collection yesterday modeling three
neutral tone versions of the brand's
popular fit pro earbuds of her own
design in an instagram teaser video she
posted earlier today the star war
metallic bronze zip front crop top and
matching bike shorts as the team applied
her makeup and adjusted the headphones
in her ear
so she has released three
beats by dre
headphones in three different neutral
colors
so
this is like a crazy collab i feel like
this is like doing a collab with apple
you know beats by dre is like such a
premium top tier
billion dollar company and i and i know
kim has always been this way i just feel
like recently she's really been in her
mogul era yeah and she's doing a lot of
endorsements
considering she has so many um
lines of her own that she has to promote
like skims and skook in
and now she is also doing beyond meat
and beets
you know what
that's a good call and i feel like it
has to do with the fact that like in the
last year she's done like a lot of
partnerships but also in the last year i
feel like she's been in the best place
publicly like people are really coming
around on kim like
like
beyond the die hard fans i mean like
overall public perception people have
really come to respect her businesses
her work on social justice like i think
this is like the mo and it is it's like
the most popular she's ever been but
it's also i think like the most
well-received she's ever been that's
interesting and i think she she got a
lot of sympathy when you know all that
kanye stuff was going down
and she was like this you know 40 year
old woman and
dating a younger guy like i think a lot
more people are opening themselves up to
like kim where some people just for no
reason are like oh those kardashians
yeah yeah that's a good point
so she's probably worth more now than
ever
and i think for a while like she was
obviously getting offered brand deals
but like the money wasn't worth
tarnishing her brand and now not only is
the money so good but these are brands
that
only bring kim up yeah yeah these are
factual points that you're making and i
do think like for her to put her name on
something that's not her own business
like she needs a big paycheck and now
she's commanding those checks even
though like for me she should have been
getting them for 10 years but yeah
right of course now the thing is like i
want to support kim love love love but
you know i'm not a beats by dre
girly like especially when it comes to
bluetooth air uh headphones which i i
don't really love
like i'm going airpods and i'm not even
going airpods new generation because i
don't like those little like siliconey
shits you put in your ear i like the og
airpods even though mine work for a
total of 25 seconds before the battery
dies yeah i use my earpods but i'm
actually open to a new product because
i'm not sold on my airpods like i think
they're really faulty and shitty and i
actually just bought these headphones
these podcast headphones yesterday i was
when you went to take your antibiotic i
was telling everyone about my new look
um in between talking [ __ ] about you and
i wish that she had come out with a big
chunky pair of headphones in those
neutral colors i would have bought one
look that one looks like my hair color
it would look so good
yeah i'm very much into wired headphones
obviously they're not a perfect product
the wire becomes like [ __ ] annoying
like what am i supposed to do with this
thing all day and
it has its problems especially when
you're using it on a phone like how the
[ __ ] am i supposed to listen to music
and charge my phone on the airplane
but i think it's better i have regressed
and i feel like with technology like you
never regress you're always moving
forward getting the better phone the new
phone the new product and like a year
ago i went back to my wired headphones
that plug into my charging port and i
never looked back yeah so i hope that
they extend this line to big chunky
headphones because i'm not obsessed with
air pods that's where we got our air air
pods and i'm not obsessed with bluetooth
earphones and if i am like
gonna use them i'm gonna use the apple
ones sadly
for now
for now but they do look really nice on
her stories i was really being
influenced and what's so great about her
and why her brand is so successful is
like she really brings her aesthetic to
everything she does and when i saw
those headphones i'm like oh my god
skims made headphones like it's really
her aesthetic yeah true that oh and
that's on being consistent i just wanted
to give an update because i was using my
skikkin last night because i washed my
hair i don't know if you could tell and
i just like was treating myself to five
minutes of self-care and as you should
and i went through the skikkin uh whole
like nine step regimen usually i use
like one or two i switch it up i like to
switch up my skincare every day um and i
just love it so much and i think it's
such a great product and i've been using
it for a few months now and like this
isn't an ad or anything but i always
wanted to like update it's hard to give
a review of a skincare product right
when you get it because you need time
but i have nothing but wonderful things
to say about skin and if like you're on
the fence or need specific products like
they're all great
good
so there's my review official
review is in for that price point they
better be great yeah but i know like
people were
i haven't heard a lot of
users fanfare saying like the actual
products are good they look yeah and
also they do
look nice in my bathroom i was worried
that they wouldn't vibe but they vibe
i'm so relaxed i know everyone was so
worried about the vibe in my desk i was
i was the truckers are here you hear
them trackers they're worried about the
vibe
truckers for skikkin
i feel like i just said something bad i
don't know why i like a curse word truck
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story
i
am
do you have another advertisement or not
no we have dear toasters yeah about that
i don't know if today's my day for dear
toasters
what do you mean i just don't think i
have the head space today to give good
advice
girlie pop we're doing it to the story
okay i'm warning you
this and final story mindy kaling says
rumors about bj novak being her
children's father don't bother her
mindy can't be true
mindy kaling is addressing the rumors
that her longtime friend bj novak could
be the father of her children in an
interview with marie claire published on
tuesday that never have i ever creator
who has kept the paternity of her
children private revealed that the
speculation about bj novak possibly
fathering her children doesn't bother
her quote he's the godparent to both of
my kids and they have such a great
relationship and so far the rumors
haven't affected my happiness at all it
hasn't affected my kids or bj she said
if that's what's going to be titillating
to people i'll take it
wait the i didn't know that he was their
godfather and the fact that he is like
makes me think he's not the dad he is
not the father
i mean
was it ever confirmed that it was like
someone we know or someone she knows
like it wasn't like a sperm donor nope
she never spoke about the paternity but
people just feel like it's bj
right and i don't really care about the
paternity not because i don't care but
because it's none of my [ __ ] business
like that's insanely invasive um
and i actually was thinking about mindy
kaling the other day she's obviously
doing like a lot of press because i saw
these gorge photos of her
um
in marie claire and then she was on
watch weapons live and she just like
looked amazing and she was being funny
and she's like if you ever
do you ever just like sit back and think
about certain people
yes but not mindy
and so i was sitting back and thinking
about her and i was like just like damn
she's really someone who got
where she is like because she's so
talented like there's so many people
that were on the office like and it was
their breakout role even bj novak and
none of them have accomplished like
literally what mindy kaling has
accomplished and she's so funny and
she's so talented and she's a really
good
like she has her finger on the trigger
of like what's cool and popular and like
the culture yeah and i watch never have
i ever i think it's great um and i just
love her like for real i agree she's
another one who like really gets
involved behind the scenes puts herself
in her own project but also no
she's a real mogul sex lives with
college girls is her most recent work
that i've seen and it's just so
fantastic
yeah like i said and she knows what's
relevant when you fear at this point
when you hear that mindy kaling is
attached to something like it gives it a
level of gravitas where it's like okay
this isn't gonna be garbage no you know
it's gonna be good and it's gonna not
gonna be like cringy or like it's gonna
accurately represent like what it's like
to be young right now yeah
she's great and i was just like sitting
back and like thinking about her because
i literally forgot she was on the office
true zack's always watching the office
so i'm always subject to think about and
she actually doesn't have a big role
from what i've seen she's kind of like
guest um
but so many of the people really are so
big from the office and like just to the
office parrot like some people don't
even do other things other than like go
on cameo and be their office brian
gardner he's he's what the the he makes
the most money on cameo of all the
people on the platform um i feel that
i do yeah people interesting the whole
office thing is crazy it's all so crazy
that it's
what's that guy's name steve carol steve
carell and like now he is
like probably one of the top actors
i was also thinking about steve carell
the other day because i saw clip on tick
tock from um
little miss sunshine which is just
an incredible movie that i forgot he was
in and it's i was thinking about him too
like sitting back and just thinking the
arc of his career from like funny man
funny man funny man overnight like
serious actor
yeah
i'm sure it wasn't overnight for him i'm
sure it was a very targeted precise
trajectory
but it's crazy how he goes from being
michael scott like biggest clown alive
to
serious steve
and i've seen a lot of episodes of the
office not all of them um and i am here
to tell you like the worst part of the
show and part of the reason why i never
fully sat down and watched the series
from start to finish is steve carrell's
character
so i just think it's interesting that
he's so famous when literally i've
wanted to put my hands around his throat
and choke him through the tv screen on
the office he's so [ __ ] annoying and
stupid the whole show is annoying and
stupid
there are moments and actually indicates
there are moments i've seen enough like
to say yeah there are moments but
i couldn't sit through watching it just
for those few moments
and mindy kaling on watch robin's live
was asked like what her top five
favorite episodes of the office are and
obviously i haven't seen all of them but
i do have a favorite episode like one
that i will go back and actually like
watch clips on youtube it's so funny and
it's called diversity day
and it's
her favorite episode too and she was
like i think it might have been taking
down on some of some streaming services
like it's hella
crass and she's like that's my favorite
episode i'm so glad we did it because
like you could never get something like
that made today it was hysterical that's
so funny i can also tell you've been
watching old toast clips because you've
resurfaced hella
wow
you're so observant yeah there was a
time where you were saying it hella
often
and while you were watching all tools
clips yesterday and i was reminded of
those times and now you've brought it
back to the four
i think that's good that way none of our
good like jokes or
limericks or phrases get lost yeah and
it's good because you are like a west
coast surfer girl
and it's important that people know that
cowabunga dude hello
hello
hello
hello
let me be your hella
was that the fifth story that was the
fifth
and final story
fabulous we'll be up to your toasters
our advice segment where you guys write
into us and we do our absolute best to
navigate you through
whatever it is that you're going through
the email to write in is dear toasters
gmail.com if you want your prompt read
on air please this is a reminder just to
keep it as brief as possible because um
we just don't like really care that much
we just
i'm kidding we just don't have that much
time like just give us the need to know
details because we want to help you but
if we start reading a whole essay on
here people are going to tune out and
just it's important we do care that was
like a joke it was really funny we
actually care a lot but like i try to
get really invested um
and that's what i'm going to do
dear toast is brought to you by liquid
iv one stick of liquid iv into 16 ounces
of water will hydrate you two times more
fast two times more fast two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone their products taste great with 10
refreshing flavors like concord grape
lemon lime pina colada and tropical
punch sounds like summer here's how it
works liquid iv comes in these little
packets you put it into 16 ounces of
water and that'll hydrate you super fast
it contains a ton of vitamins b3 b5 b6
b12 vitamin c it has three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks and it's made with the most
premium ingredients in the world so
whatever you need hydration for
this is the product for you personally i
need hydration all the time because i
never drink water and especially when
i'm hungover i'm always looking for a
product to help and liquid iv is amazing
like really make it before you go to bed
it'll change your life or the next
morning the electrolytes are so good
also if you just get dehydrated you get
migraines hydration is always important
they're also a great company they change
the world they are donating servings to
someone in need for every purchase
that's made so grab your liquid iv in
bulk nationwide at costco or you can get
15 off when you go to liquidive.com use
code toast 15 off anything you order
at liquidive.com using promo code toast
all right you ready for these your
toaster submissions yeah and they just
want to say like i was so excited about
these headphones but they are
exacerbating my headaches so
oh it's like a headband yep i do yours
not give you a headache
no jackie what came first the headphones
of the headache the head the headache
came first then the headphones made it
worse
got it uh no mind you not give me a
headache i'll send you the the brand
they're super loose just like me
[Laughter]
dear jackson claude how you doing
long time toaster first time dear
toasters writer you need to buckle up i
wonder if you've had anyone who has
written twice and been read twice
let us know
my brother-in-law brad and his wife lucy
were recently married in february
they were engaged earlier last year and
also had a baby together in october 2021
prior to getting married my best friend
bridget and lucy have always been
somewhat flirty touchy
towards each other no one ever thought
anything of it bridget is generally
always like that with most girls until
recently lucy and bridget kissed which
led to them hooking up to them now
wanting to be in a full-on relationship
so her best friend and her sister-in-law
uh
so like just the two of them
oh i don't know let's see at first brad
was not upset when he found out that
lucy and bridget had kiss but now that
he knows about them hooking up and
wanting to be exclusive brad has zero
clue what to do and neither do i or my
husband who's brad's brother
brad wants to work this out with lucy so
badly for the sake of their marriage and
their baby but lest we not forget that
my best friend is also intertwined in
this it's really putting me in a pickle
with her as well as my husband's family
and i have zero clue on how to navigate
this please give your honest advice on
how you would handle the situation love
a toaster stuck between a rock and a
hard place well this is weird like is
lucy trying to leave brad like what she
just said
yes she but like that's not what she
said she said they want to be exclusive
like in a relationship therefore not in
a relationship so divorce with brad so
divorce divorce yeah no i guess that's
true that's a weird way of
saying yeah i feel like she's just like
wants to stay married and be in a
relationship with bridget but they
should be a tripod
it's giving bronwyn energy and even
broadman ended up getting divorced
because she did not like her husband so
i agree i think
i mean the girl who wrote in is like not
involved so i think which the question
she's asking is like how do i navigate
this like this is my husband's family
brad is my family now but lucy's my
friend you don't do anything you sit
back watch grab some popcorn and see
what happens
yeah but if if you do have to choose a
side like you have to choose bradside
i agree
like family's family and he was wrong
like he was wronged and yeah i totally
agree and he's your family and even
though bridget is your friend like she's
acting
like not
a friend not a friend yeah and she's
learning a happy family like no she's
like running a muck and not like caring
about the consequences of her actions
yeah like there's a child involved yeah
the thing the thing is if somebody does
seek out your advice like brad lucy any
of the people involved bridgette i agree
with jackie like there might be like an
unorthodox solution to this but i can't
imagine brad who's obviously traditional
you know he got married i don't know if
he would be open to that
but there might be an answer
what the [ __ ] does brad know about
bridgette like what if brad could get
involved
right so like i would say i would
encourage everyone to be open to any
possibility
but
again
it's possible that they're not yeah and
it's a lot but for you stay out of it
for you stay out of it this is
complicated enough without you getting
your ass involved agreed
good luck to everyone yeah keep us
posted
good morning jackson claude hello
i have to start off by saying i love you
guys listening to the toast on my
commute to my first ever big girl job
has made the transition from college to
working girl that much better
last month i overheard my mom tell her
friend
that she told my dad that she should
have divorced him when she found out he
cheated on her i'm sorry say that again
yeah no it's a confusing sentence but
listen
this girl overheard her mom talking on
the phone to her friend and her mom said
on the phone
i should have told dad
no sorry i should have divorced that i'm
trying to paraphrase this and i'm making
it worse let me just read it again
last month i overheard my mom tell her
friend that she my mom told my dad that
she should have divorced him when she
found out he cheated on her
okay when did he cheat are you getting
it
yep
my mom has no idea that i heard it and i
haven't stopped thinking about it since
i love my parents and i'm the closest of
my siblings with my dad i'm also the
youngest in the family and i'm the only
child still living at home i'm 23. i
have no recollection of my parents
fighting growing up but my oldest sister
who's 26 says that she does have a
recollection i imagine this must have
happened so long ago but now i'm
constantly thinking about it and worried
that my mom will act on this feeling of
course i hate the idea that my dad could
have done that especially because my mom
deserves the world but how could i and
how could he have done that to her and
his three children
if we were alive at the time she doesn't
know when the affair was but finding
this out shattered my world do i talk to
my parents do i pretend like i never
heard it i hate confrontation and i know
the conversation will be so awkward
i mean it would be best if you found out
when this happened
obviously if it happened before you were
born like that would be really i don't
think it did because i don't think she
would say that yeah like obviously it
was like a few years ago and she thought
she was over it but now she's coming to
the realization that she ain't yeah
and if that's the case it was a few
years ago and like you're grown and your
and your family's grown like
you just have to
i don't know
see the thing is i i
uh
the only reason why normally i would say
like just forget about it but the fact
that she heard her mom like still having
doubts means a it's recent and b it's
not like it's not resolved it's still
very much up in the air yeah but you are
23 and i think maybe a good thing to
for you to do just to protect your heart
like you can't protect everyone you
can't make sure your mom or dad doesn't
get hurt but you can protect yourself
and i think for a lot of people like who
grow up with parents
who like hide all the fighting and like
the arguments and think everything's
perfect and then they're you know
suddenly 25 and their parents are
getting divorced it's like an
earth-shattering concept for them yeah
um whereas some people's parents get
divorced and it's like fairly obvious
their parents weren't ever happy
together and like it's a tough
transition but ultimately they realized
that it was the best thing for their
parents
um but there are people
who get to this place of being an adult
who still kind of idolize their parents
relationships and when they do get
divorced it's like the worst thing ever
so my advice would be like maybe start
getting comfortable with the idea of
your parents not being together because
if they do get divorced and you don't
take it well like it'll have a profound
effect on you like you've actually been
given a warning
that it might come so why don't you do
like some like not therapy but like self
do some work yeah and just get to a
place where you're comfortable with the
potential of it yeah and also like you
live at home with your parents like
whichever one you feel closer to just
talk to them about it be like i
overheard this
and i think she the vibe was that like
she is closer with her yeah well then
talk to him and be like did you cheat on
mom
the [ __ ] i actually think that's good
yeah because
that way you don't have to admit to your
mom that you were eavesdropping because
i don't know who just like magically
hears people on phone calls yeah um
and you're
coming at it from like a defensive place
you're not on the offense with your dad
so
no like you're on the offense yeah i
just
i don't know
like
maybe you should move out
well i think that's another lesson here
that you know nothing good comes from
living out as an adult because then
you're supportive of and you're pretty
like and they're having a they're still
a couple too and like couples have stuff
and now you're like living with a couple
that's true like i am actually a big fan
of moving home to save money
but and she said she's post-grad so
again no i understand why people get it
but you know then you're
kind of in the middle of stuff like this
and you're like an intruder like your
parents raised you for 18 years get the
[ __ ] out
yo if my kids come home after 18 like
you're sleeping in the yard and you'll
do chores you can live here like as a
housekeeper
like i'm finally getting my life back
[ __ ] off
yeah
i'm not into it like at all well if they
could pay rent too
they could pick so go pay rent at
someone else
they could pay your bills
i'm i take care of myself just fine
i don't need my kids to take care of me
when i'm older yes of course i want them
to buy me a beachfront condo but when
they have to give me a nurse when
they're 23 you would be about
50. i don't know it depends it depends
but like i just don't want and also i
don't think it's good for the kids like
after college you should get out you
should meet people you should date you
should make friends you should be having
crazy experiences you know you're in
your 20s for so long the [ __ ] are you
doing in my living room
yeah
yeah like and then also just like being
privy to all of this like couple drama
and also not being able to grasp the
concept of your parents relationship not
being perfect
yeah and it's like me and ben had to
like let people into our home for 18
years and now they're coming back
i don't think so
so i do think that's good get yourself
comfortable with the idea get
comfortable being uncomfortable like
your parents might get divorced sit with
that for a while and also start looking
at an apartment and even if they don't
like your parents relationship like
isn't
and hasn't always been hunky-dory
and
you're all alive and healthy
and for me as a child of divorce and
a child of a dead dad
i have and this is mean i'm sorry like i
have little to no sympathy for people
whose like biggest trauma is their
parents divorce like
kim there's people that are dying
my dad okay
yeah
ready for our third and final dear
toasters not to trauma dump on everyone
um trauma oh that's is that the new term
by the way another overused term that
means nothing anymore is trauma trauma
agreed um yeah trauma dump is when you
just like don't stop telling everyone
like your deepest darkest secrets this
podcast should be the morning trauma
dump no that sounds like i would love to
hear someone's trauma dump
i actually i don't think you would like
because i think also the concept of
transaction is like it's like you're
putting this heaviness on anyone else i
take it back it's a burden yeah never
mind
all right dear jackie and claudia long
time listener first time caller love you
both end the show my husband and i have
been married for three years and we are
expecting our first baby together in
january he's the best he's caring he's
supportive loyal amazing dog dad etc but
he has an extremely unhealthy lifestyle
he doesn't exercise at all he works from
home so aside from walking the dog he
sticks in his desk chair literally all
day he insisted we get a peloton and
hasn't been on it in months and he eats
really really unhealthy fried food lots
of sugar no fruits and veggies he's in
his 30s and at his last doctor's
appointment he was told he's overweight
and has high cholesterol i don't even
care about how he looks i love every
inch of him but i am concerned about his
health especially since we're starting a
family so how if at all do i bring this
up to him i don't want to come off as
judgmental but shouldn't partners be
able to voice concerns given we're not
only going to be living
for ourselves anymore sincerely a
concerned mama to be that's really tough
but i think a situation that's extremely
common now i know and by the way i feel
like we just spoke about this when we
were talking about luke combs oh i know
that like wait and see is not um
a plan but i do think sometimes like
becoming a father not just like you
being sometimes it happens when a woman
is pregnant and the man is like i want
to be you know around for my kid i want
to be able to throw the ball and play
catch i do think sometimes that might
happen after the baby is born and like
the
the man can like see
exactly you know and and think and
come to that realization himself i also
think again not to like have you
postpone this
but when
whenever you want to
like after you give birth and you know
take all the time you need just like
your girl here but eventually like you
might want to like lose baby weight or
whatever like that's something you can
do together and you can make it less
like you need to go lose weight and
instead be like we as a family need to
get healthy and then the whole household
changes
so i completely agree with everything
you said i was gonna say the exact same
thing like obviously your man's isn't
pregnant so it's possible like the
magnitude of what's about to happen
hasn't really hit him and i don't think
it hits a lot of guys until they
actually hold the baby because men are
just like you know slower
so i think actually it might have a
profound effect on him and how he
chooses to live his life moving forward
so i wouldn't say anything yet because i
think there's still potential for him to
come to the conclusion on his own and i
love what you just said like
he won't maybe feel attacked if you say
to him like
i'm you know i want to get back in shape
you know let's think about it like i'm
this baby's mom like we're his parents
like we have to be around for as long as
possible and in the best shape so that
we can you know be the best parent like
to come at it from a we versus you is
much less offensive and less of an
attack yeah and also you could also
bring the baby into it and be like i
want him or her to lead a healthy
lifestyle and i want them to you know us
to lead by example for him you can make
it like a whole thing and really make it
a family activity also
it's also kind of really hard to
implement something like that while you
are pregnant because at least for me
when i was pregnant like all of a sudden
we had not healthy food in the house
like it would have been so hard for me
to be like i'm buying oreos and all this
stuff for the first time that like
because i'm craving it and you can't eat
it you know
two things one i do feel as though the
fact that he like wanted a peloton means
he's open yeah like
i mean i can understand buying a peloton
and never using it like that's
definitely something i would do because
one day i'm like yeah let's do it
the other thing is that i also think
your verbiage and your phrasing is super
important because if if you're fixated
on like i want you to lose weight like
that's mean
and then
it could make him insecure that maybe
you're not attracted to him so i think
like in terms of messaging i would stay
on the key points which is just
basically health it has nothing to do
with how much you weigh it's about what
you're putting in your body
and what you that's affecting your
that's affecting your cholesterol your
heart rate like what you feel like i
would do it as like as a family we
should get healthy and you know get to a
place where you can run around the yard
with him what doesn't it's not about
what you look like in order to do that
some people are you know extremely
in shape not in shape but really thin
and
aren't like healthy enough to do that so
no but then there are people who are
bigger and people would assume that
they're completely out of shape and
they're in great shape yeah so it's it's
it's about like what's going on on his
insides
yeah exactly so i wouldn't like really
focus on numbers or weight or pounds
like just overall wellness like be very
melissa wood health about it you know
guru but it unfortunately and it's like
so annoying but it's gonna require like
you doing like the grocery shopping and
the healthy cooking and you know
in addition to have just delivered a
baby but that's on being a woman
literally
so do all that when you are good and
ready yeah don't do anything yet like
just don't stress yourself out enjoy the
rest of your pregnancy eat whatever you
want um
but wait and see if he comes to it on
his own i fee i have faith i feel like
he might yeah
you'll you'll be
okay i feel like you did a good job even
though i know you have a headache yeah
no i got once i'm into it i'm into it
thank you to everyone who wrote in again
that's dear toasters gmail.com
every wednesday here on the morning
toast that's our show love you jax love
you clerd
thank you
i do love you clerk
thank you so much for listening to the
morning chest the monday morning show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up rose available podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitch republican radio i
really can't box all the places where
listen to the podcast venus foreign
smart we are have an amazing day you
guys we'll see you tomorrow bye
you